hi i'm benedict cumberbatch I'm here at
BuzzFeed and I'm here to play with
puppies and to answer your questions
I'm excited I'm sizing me the pups bring
in the pups what's what what is
depression what's the best and worst
thing about playing dr. strange um the
best thing is yeah you eat that question
eat it up yeah yeah there's a lot of
best things about it best thing is
probably having a cloak that means I can
fly which means I get to do violet which
when it's done right and not for too
long in a harness is incredibly good fun
some of the stunts are really good fun
to do the training and all of that I
really enjoy it it's a big workout the
worst thing is I don't know it's a
really gifted gig I'm very lucky
I'm too known about something what would
it be maybe maybe the cloak again the
cloak is quite cumbersome no pun
intended
and oh yeah it can be quite a sort of
awkward thing to work with cookie jar no
I'm joking it's just questions I'm so
sorry do you still know how to play the
violin if so which I do I still know I
never knew how to play the violin next
question it was all fakery and really
embarrassing you know this is something
that takes years of practice from the
age of three and then I'm supposed to
sort of turn it round in a couple of
months before doing a bit of Sherlock
not good my friends I could tend to be a
lot of things with some degree of
authenticity but that is something well
me if there was a season five of
Sherlock what would you want to happen
to your character
next question who's the first real
friend you made in Hollywood and do two
still speak I don't know I mean yes we
still speak first time I went to
Hollywood I did Star Trek and I don't
speak to them nearly I mean Zoe I see
more of obviously because of the Marvel
thing but it crisp like the door and
minoan Zachary as well yeah it was it
was it was a it is a great family was a
great family to be pass over for a
little while there
I'm dumbing Anton as well I wish I could
still speak to very sad don't eat my
questions before I've read them it's
like having naked flames in there this
is wonderful how hard was it to jump
back into your normal life after playing
were like Patrick mowers a good question
difficult i extracted myself from my
normal life for a little while
especially when I went to the dark zone
of became the heroin abuse and trashing
hotel rooms in the New York episode just
didn't really want to go home with any
of that swelling around my brain and
body I mean not literally but just
psychically and well I'm physically
because you just have to pretend and put
yourself down it just you need some
space but most of the time I switch on
and off pretty easily which app on your
phone do you use the most probably
weighs hey go easy you may be bigger but
that's not playing fair stop it stop it
no no no no no no no no no no if you
could do a film adaptation of any TV
show you loved as a child what was it
which one would it be
why did I want to do films of something
that worked well in its time is the TV
series I mean take everyone that happens
a lot but I'm that that's not really
that's not my gig I don't know too fond
of that stuff are you ever going to join
Instagram or Twitter did neither no
absolutely not
who are your all-time favorite musicians
which present artists are you listening
to nowadays I have an all-time favorite
I mean bowing the stones Ramones Sex
Pistols clash Oh Pink Floyd what a
menacing certainly well elbows in your
arm it's great moon shaped pool gets a
lot of playing Radiohead's I love Tom's
new album as well it's a very good film
he did with Paul Thomas Anderson things
are serious what is your relative choose
my boot describe a puffy take over this
is a perfect day isn't it getting my ear
licked by puppy yes pretty perfect this
is great but I mean the rest of perfect
with me would be private so I won't
describe it
and work-wise though a perfect day is I
don't know I love my job
pretty much every day is a good one holy
days one I've had eight hours sleep it's
a perfect day what are some of you've
all pet peeves
so grouchy with all these questions I
don't know people leaning on the horn
thinking it's gonna make traffic move
faster people be trapped in that bubble
you know people being trapped in the
bubble full-stop live off phone usage
negative impact of summer social media I
mean I could go on I'm an old fogy now
43 sufficiently good question I really
could go on siwell dirty-tricks
demagoguery fake news everyone's a
critic and angry but they don't
necessarily have any kind of new ones
they just want to shoot the messenger
sometimes not a message the fact that
we're in a crisis people a climate
crisis these little puppy dogs save the
puppies if not yourselves stop using
single-use plastic try and stop taking
carbon fuels out of the ground please
leave the fossil fuels alone for these
puppies it's a dangerous question to
give me yeah can I another pet pet
burning rainforests what the [ __ ] is
wrong with the world what was it like
babysitting Tom Holland during rooms see
you pressed it was difficult like I said
I had to teach kid how to shave how to
brush his teeth the fact he had to do it
both day and night you know personal
hygiene is a bit of an issue with
teenagers and Tom's no exception to that
rule so you know I can forget the rooms
I could get out you know that kind of it
was it was tricky but you know he's
analysis he's a gentleman brilliant wise
beyond his years
tolerant than me and a dear friend I
loved working with him bring on the next
project goodbye thanks so much
I'm Benedict Cumberbatch what's my movie
let's call the current war it's not mine
most other people - that's pretty good
North Shore Animal League America Thank
You puppies and thank you for looking
after them
[Music]